- I think the problem is
we don't die quick enough.
(audience laughs)
Somebody said to me the other day,
"You know, in 40 years, you'll be 79."
And I thought,
"How long is this going to go on for?"
(audience laughs)
We just keep living,
so you have to keep coming
up with things to do.
And that's why you're here,
so you've done something tonight.
(audience laughs)
'Cause tomorrow, people will say,
"What did you do last night?"
And you can say,
"I went to this comedy show,
because I live in London,
I'm alive, I'm alive."
(audience laughs)
Are you though?
Or are you just desperately
filling the time
so you don't have to feel any pain.
(audience laughs)
Well you came to the wrong show.
(gentle piano music)